good morning Internet I'm Ilana welcome
to my channel it's a Monday and today I
thought that I would take you with me on
my various Monday adventures did I
mention I'm back in Australia because I
have been for like a month
boom clothed cockaroach Indonesia
especially when the jeans like to size
is too big and the t-shirt is a
Dragonball Z reference but because I'm
going to film today I have to grab a
second t-shirt because I swapped
t-shirts when I film so that it looks
like I'm filming on different days and
this is effectively how I choose the
shirt done
doing my eyebrows in this phone camera
was a terrible idea
got that labrador hair on them white
jeans suitably covered in dog hair and
now we drive to work let's go
it's really freaking hot today it's
winter why is it so hot it was like five
degrees last night and Malin during the
day it's like 25 this is ridiculous
one of the things that I never got used
to living in the US was when I was
driving and the radio in cars would have
American accents I know that always just
sounded like a parody to me because of
video games it would be the same if I
saw a police car I would always feel
like that's a fictional police car
police don't really look like that but
also because I was there for 7 months
and did a fair bit of driving I'm bad at
driving on both sides of the road now I
I have no idea which lane to turn in Ewa
in every country in the world and I
wouldn't recommend it so we are now at
work this is where I film stuff so this
is what everything looks like probably
set up I will stand roughly here please
camera there and we have is the scripts
that I wrote yesterday that we then put
on this which then acts as a
teleprompter for me to read it's fancy
sneaky shut change to nobody will know
we actually filmed two episodes on the
same day so that is what completed I
basically go that one or two times a
week to film the scripts that I write
during the week and now I'm gonna go get
some coffee
and then I'm going to go to uni model
lyrics in this song lotta lyrics
coffee
haha got a big Nintendo supporter in
front of us here check it out yeah going
in mother [ __ ] so this is my university
campus I technically have two campuses
because my degree is split between
creative industries and business um
so the business one is in different
campus but today I have entertainment
marketing probably not going to take you
into class with me because that would be
rude and weird so I'll see you
afterwards so that's done came out and
it's dark the Sun sets so early over
here compared to California and it trips
me out every time but this is my fourth
and last year of university I'm studying
Mass Communication majoring in
journalism and entertainment so you know
basically a giant waste of time
I'm totally anti uni if you can avoid
studying don't do it I've just come so
far it would be dumb for me to not
finish it now but work experience over
studying always even if it means like
volunteering somewhere for a while it's
going to be more valuable than sitting
in a class and being taught crap you'll
forget just I hate the system have so
many problems with the education system
so it's time to drive home again it may
be 5:30 but the day is still young still
got plenty of stuff to do so let's go do
it
oh just not home hello chills how large
else what are you doing look how cute
she is hi mom hi
chose these pants used to be white look
at the male look what you've done look
what you've done look at what have you
done that is obviously not enough cheese
and this is my first Huntsman sighting
keep I've been back in the country
they're enormous and terrifying look at
the size of that look at the size that's
fired up
okay oh so I've just finished watching a
bunch of Netflix with my family have now
gone to bed so I'm having some green tea
and I'm going to video at it a little so
while we let that export for the next
hour I'm going to go to the gym going to
take my makeup off so today is a
shoulders triceps and pecs day which
basically means that I do like two
different exercises that work out that
muscle group and I do three by twelve
reps of each of those exercises but I
probably also do thirty minutes cardio
even though I hate cardio so I tend to
put it off but you know today we'll do
it
okay walkout completed the cardio is
just as awful as I thought it would be
regret did you mean did you miss me and
now we have some tasty tasty egg whites
for tasty tasty protein and it will you
boil the kettle so I can have some green
tea when again out of the shower shower
completed so right now I'm going to
start uploading that YouTube video and
then I need to record a bunch of
gameplay for work recording gameplay
does require a little bit of work so we
have my laptop my ps4 and my Elgato and
I just need to connect them all it also
technically actually has to be through
my Xbox one because that's how I'm
running the ps4 through the TV function
on the Xbox one Xbox go to TV so like
the strange is in two consoles later and
it is on my laptop ready to hit that big
red button to record that set is on we
are ready to go I'll be doing this for
about an hour or so now
wish me luck okay gameplay recording has
been completed I am really freaking
tired hearing sleep yeah that's a pretty
standard Monday other days of the week
for me involve playing games that I have
to review and sitting on my laptop and
writing scripts but I hope you guys have
enjoyed this video I'm going to post the
hell out right now I will see you next
time boy